qu'on va faire tu vas essayer de faire
la promo avec alban d'inséparables je
vous propose donc une interview où vous
allez doit faire des accents à chaque
fois il y aura des drapeaux nouvelle
école dans le team honda essaie de me
faire la promo du film alors attention
au premier drapeau c'est le drapeau à la
wii l'accent à ce que tu feras nuit
magique de supporter parce que là je
vous le redis dans le film a fait à
mettre son gros truc c'est qu'il essaie
de faire les allemands avec des actions
mais en fait à chaque fois il fait que
la grille où c'est le cas tu as eu
d'yeux belgique belgique ont embrasé
hier nos amis belges ils nous regardent
ils sont très nombreux dans ces cafés
dix ans de prison alors on a aussi le
drapeau et on a on a les antilles bien
entendu on a d'ailleurs tous qu'il est
chaud il est chez nous on a regardé dans
tiendront les entailles l'effort d'aller
partir sur un axe anglais ce n'est pas
beaucoup et vous allez voir je vois bien
un film
depuis des temps pour la famille
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
dollar c'est à duke album madonna
isabelle boutinon est donc en fait lui
dedans il n'aime pas l'impôt lutter site
appelé les gens et appelait les gens
pourront s'arrêter là
[Applaudissements]